et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Patrick Le Canard bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous pour cette émission
spéciale consacrée à la réforme des
retraites sénateurs du Nord président du
groupe socialiste au Sénat Patrick Anna
vous déposez ce matin une motion
référendaire contre cette réforme des
retraites quel objectif sachant qu'elle
sera repoussée elle sera sûrement
repoussée ce miracle bien longtemps je
ne crois plus aux miracle mais au moins
elle aura l'intérêt de dire que sur un
sujet aussi important aussi polémique
qui touche quand même des millions de
nos concitoyens
est-il anormal qu'on essaye de les
consulter et puis je vais prendre un mot
un peu ce qu'a dit
Monsieur Macron il y a quelques jours
avant le salon de l'agriculture il a dit
mais je fais confiance au bon sens des
Français bah je suis le président
allons-y faisons confiance au bon sang
des Français et le meilleur moyen c'est
de leur demander leur avis
qui représente la républicains dit mais
dans ces cas-là faisant aussi un
référendum sur la loi immigration c'est
ce qu'on demande est-ce que vous serez
vous seriez prêt à l'accepter non non
parce que c'était pas le même sujet si
vous voulez là on est sur un migration
et d'éventuelles régularisation c'est un
mot qui n'aime pas manifestement ça ça
rentre quand même dans le pouvoir
régalien de l'État là on est sur un
problème de société c'est typiquement de
l'article 11
réformé par la Constitution de 2008 donc
et puis les Français je veux dire là ils
sont vraiment concernés ils sont
vraiment directement concernés par ce
texte et par cette augmentation de l'âge
de légal de la retraite donc n'ayons pas
peur n'ayons pas peur et les Français
vont exprimer on va en parler sûrement
leurs colères leur désaccords
cette mars prochain mais est-ce que vous
qui demandez du temps pour l'examen de
cette réforme est-ce que là ce n'est pas
en faire perdre au Sénat
non non puisque le Sénat et ajuste titre
a pris des dispositions pour qu'on
débate longtemps beaucoup plus qu'à
l'Assemblée 106 heures de mémoire chez
nous 60 heures à l'Assemblée et
d'ailleurs ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée totalement anormale bon il y
a eu les éclats de voile les insultes
les menaces et ce qui s'est passé en
terme d'image mais il me faut jamais
oublier que il y a eu aussi une décision
de la majorité de l'Assemblée nationale
et donc du président de la République et
de ses amis pour ne pas ouvrir le
week-end les travaux
pour quelles raisons nourrirez pas
comment on le fait chez nous d'ailleurs
les travaux pendant deux week-end on
aurait gagné 4 jours de travail on n'a
pas déplacé la niche des socialistes qui
avaient demandé à ce qu'on déplace leur
niche pour justement récupérer une
journée de travail donc il y a eu de
l'obstruction et la première obstruction
c'est bien sûr le véhicule législatif
qui a été utilisé mais aussi la manière
dont à l'assemblée a été à gérer et ça a
été mieux géré au Sénat
vous connaissez que du coup il a il
organise bien les débats ici comme
toujours monsieur l'archet consulte les
présidents de groupe respectent son
opposition
et nous avons pu effectivement discuter
avec lui le rythme des débats même si au
bout du bout et ça a été appelé par
Monsieur carochi sans qu'il rentre dans
le détail je l'ai bien compris il y aura
l'utilisation de du fameux article 38 du
Règlement du Sénat pour limiter le temps
de parole des des élus de l'opposition
à dire matin dans Le Figaro qu'il allait
utiliser tous les outils pour aller au
bout du texte c'est ce que vous en
pensez
à ceux et à celles qui nous regardent
que l'article 38 ça consiste simplement
à dire que sur un article d'amendement
voir sur tout le texte mais bon je n'ai
pas imaginer cela mais sur un article ou
sur un amendement quelqu'un dit oui
quelqu'un dit non et ça suffirait pour
arrêter le débat c'est une sorte de 49,3
le modèle Sénat
qu'il a jamais été utilisé qui était je
crois intégré en 2015 de mémoire dans le
règlement du Sénat donc c'est vraiment
un coup près terrible et surtout il y a
quelque chose qui ne colle pas qui peut
d'ailleurs poser un problème
constitutionnel s'il était utilisé c'est
que on considère que un pour un conte
que donc un pour quel que soit la
diversité potentielle des pour et un
contre quel que soit la diversité
potentielle des contre ça veut dire que
qu'est-ce qui parle pour le contre c'est
un socialiste c'est un communiste c'est
inverse c'est un radical parce qu'il y a
des radicaux qui nous soutiennent dans
cette démarche donc c'est quand même
drôle de manière de gérer la démocratie
de ne pas utiliser cet article 38
clairement
bien sûr je souhaite que le débat aille
jusqu'au bout et encore une fois le
jusqu'au bout c'est le 12 mars à minuit
et ce n'est pas de notre fait si ce
jusqu'au bout est prévu à l'avance c'est
parce que le gouvernement a décidé
d'utiliser là aussi encore une fois ce
projet de loi de finance rectificative
qui pour moi est absolument incroyable
par rapport à l'objet même de la loi
mais est-ce que vous souhaitez que les
20 articles du texte soient examinés
je souhaite qu'il soit examiné oui
puisque il fallait jusqu'au bout mais ce
n'est pas de notre fête si on n'y arrive
pas mais est-ce que vous souhaitez qu'il
y ait un vote final
mais nous on souhaite qu'il y a des bas
sur l'article 7 parce que c'est voilà
c'est ce que vous souhaitez qu'il y a un
vote sur ce texte et à la fin puisqu'on
nous impose un rythme de débat qui ne
nous convient pas et même si la droite
veut avoir son texte et bien s'il n'est
pas voté et bien ça affaiblira
globalement le texte c'est ça la vraie
question
parce que la droite du Sénat veut son
texte et on l'a bien vu hier j'ai écouté
vous avez écouté Monsieur Bruno
retaillod dans la dans la discussion
générale qu'est-ce qu'il dit il dit mais
je suis un homme heureux ce soir
je retrouve le clivage droite-gauche
mais la raison il a raison
clivage droite-gauche pour moi c'est une
respiration démocratique extrêmement
importante mais si vous êtes heureux de
retrouver ce rêve je suis très heureux
et je suis très heureux que les masques
enfin tombent et que et bien la macronie
de
l'entre-deux du en même temps etc non la
macronie est une partie de la droite
différente de LR c'est une la droite
libérale anglo-saxonne et là vous avez
la droite
classique française mais ce sont des
membres de la même droite et aujourd'hui
je le dis à d'anciens amis et d'ailleurs
ça m'a fait un peu de peine de voir hier
au banc monsieur Attal et Monsieur Usopp
ancien socialiste
c'est aussi de l'ancienne gauche qui qui
porte en fin de compte oui et qui porte
vous voyez une réforme de droite très
dure très dur parce qu'elle touche
encore une fois la majorité au profit
d'une minorité et
sûrement il y a quelques années il
aurait combattu vraiment backs et ongles
c'est comme ça la vie est-ce que parce
que vous m'avez pas répondu clairement
est-ce que clairement vous allez faire
en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de vote ou
est-ce que vous sentez qu'il y a un vote
nous pensons que les articles le suivant
l'article 7 mérite beaucoup plus de
débats que ce qui nous est annoncé donc
voilà donc on va nous présenter nos
amendements nous allons présenter nos
arguments nous allons défendre nos
explications de vote nous allons faire
parole sur article amendements parce
qu'il y a quasiment 4000 amendements de
la gauche je ne retirais pas vos
amendements pour aboutir à votre final
les amendements du groupe socialiste je
ne parle que de moi que de mon groupe
les amendes du groupe c'est moins de 500
amendements moins de 500 amendements que
pas énorme après il y a des amendements
individuels qui ont été déposés et
pourquoi ils ont été les poser et bien
en prévention
de l'utilisation du fameux article 38
pour nous permettre de nous exprimer
quand même voyez c'est et on verra bien
comment se comporte les uns et les
autres donc qui dit un parlementaire
c'est fait pour voter bien sûr mais
est-ce qu'un parlementaire s'est fait
pour accepter le coup de force d'un
gouvernement c'est ça la question qui
nous est posée et nous nous disons non
nous ne voulons pas accepter le coup de
force du Gouvernement sur ce texte de
loi
gouvernement qui n'entend plus rien
enfin excusez-moi mais bon il y a
quelques mesures et quelques sucrettes
comme je les appelle par rapport à la
pilule amère que représente l'article 7
mais on est dans une forme de
bunkérisation aujourd'hui de l'exécutif
un président de la République qui
s'exprime pas d'ailleurs sur le sujet
des retraites ou très peu qui laisse
monter bien sûr je pense qu'il faut
qu'il supprime les Français vont lui
dire le 7 mars monsieur le Président
nous ne voulons pas de votre réforme
y compris parmi ceux qui ont voté pour
lui et vous avez vu les ratios et
d'ailleurs pour lui-même dans son image
il augmente un petit peu chez les
retraités en termes de sondage de
d'opinion positifs mais il baisse très
très fort chez les actifs donc les
actifs ont bien compris qu'il serait les
premiers victimes de cette réforme quand
même le président qui défend sa réforme
il affaire Rungis au salon de
l'agriculture il a fait également il dit
que c'est au Sénat d'enrichir le texte
est-ce que ce n'est pas bien qu'il
laisse la main il a trouvé au Sénat la
majorité qui n'a pas à l'Assemblée
nationale
qui est le marionnettiste qui est la
marionnette on verra bien dans les
quelques jours qui viennent
le groupe LR pense être le
marionnettiste
je pense qu'au bout du bout il a fermé
votée ce sera pour le gain du président
de la République et pas pour
l'opposition de droite qui d'ailleurs
n'est plus maintenant sont véritablement
sur l'opposition sur l'examen de
l'article 7 est-ce que vous avez trouvé
un accord avec Gérard Larcher pour qu'il
soit examiné après la journée
je pense que dans la sagesse du Sénat y
compris de la droite mais aussi de la
gauche chacun comprend que l'expression
des Français le 7 mars est importante
d'être connu avant le débat sur
l'article 7 donc il y a une forme
d’accord tacite on verra bien s'il sera
respecté je je savais moi comme saint
Thomas je verrais bien un moment venu
elle soit très forte
il peut y avoir des changements parce
que vous savez et vous savez les
sénateurs de droite euh bah ils sont
dans des territoires où il y aura
beaucoup de manifestations beaucoup de
mobilisation je n'oublie pas qu'il y a
une petite élection en septembre
prochain au Sénat et que les mers vont
regarder ce que font leur sénateurs etc
donc oui influera sur les sénatoriales
de septembre je pense que même si le
texte est voté au bout du bout parce que
il y aurait une majorité notamment grâce
au Sénat je pense que ça laissera des
traces longues et pénibles et pénible
donc oui il peut y avoir une influence
de cristal en tirer un bénéfice pour le
groupe socialiste écoutez nous nous
sommes clairs et droit dans le vote on
considère que cette réforme est mauvaise
les mères qui sont nos grands électeurs
voient bien que leur population est
contre cette réforme et donc nous nous
aurons été en opposition
jusqu'au bout en opposition mais en
proposition puisque nous ferons bien sûr
par les abonnements des propositions
alternatives on va y venir mais un
dernier mot puisque le 7 mars on l'a dit
cette journée de mobilisation ton pantin
pendant l'examencienna comment vous
allez marquer le coup comment les
sénateurs socialisent vont marquer le
coup est-ce que ce sera temps dans la
rue ou est-ce qu'il y aura quelque chose
dans l'hémicycle
on n'est pas on n'est pas pour mettre
des banderoles dans l'hémicycle vous
l'imaginez bien donc on va regarder cela
permettez nous encore une fois dans
discuter d'abord entre nous quelques-uns
quelques-uns d'entre nous serons
présents dans le dans la manifestation
notamment à Paris mais nous serons déjà
très nombreux présents le 7 mars et
c'est une manière aussi de dire aux
Français qu'ils peuvent compter sur
certes une minorité 93 monsieur caoutchi
la martelé à plusieurs reprises avant
que je n'arrive sur votre plateau mais
93 voix puissantes qui défendent
finalement la justice sociale ça peut
peser dans les débats
soyez patiente
alors sur le fond la gauche affirme et
affiche un son unité dans cette bataille
on l'a vu vous avez fait une conférence
de presse avant le début lors de votre
conférence de presse Eliane assassy a
défendu le retour à la retraite à 60 ans
est-ce que c'est une position qui est
partagée par l'enfant
c'est une position qui un moment donné a
été écrit vous le savez bien dans un
corps électoral la suite de la nu
pendant les élections législatives moi
je pense que aujourd'hui nous avons une
réforme qui existe qui va donc être
potentiellement modifié la réforme
Touraine qui est un juste équilibre en
fait entre voilà augmenter
raisonnablement le nom de trimestre
cotisé pour pouvoir bénéficier de de sa
retraite pour être clair c'est 43 à 8
heures d'ici 2035 là ça va être ramené à
2027 donc c'est une accélération
considérable de la réforme Touraine plus
le départ à 64 ans donc nous nous sommes
pour non pas le statu quo nous sommes
pour revenir sur les critères qui ont
été annulés un exemple très concret en
2017 ordonnance de Madame Pénicaud mini
du travail à l'époque sur commande de
Monsieur Macron suppression de quatre
critères de pénibilité bien nous allons
demander à ce qu'on les retrouve parce
que dans les madame Touraine il y avait
une partie je dirais plus dur à savoir
l'augmentation du monde de trimestre
mais aussi il y avait
l'écriture pour les carrières difficiles
et pour les carrières longues je sais
qu'il y avait commencé tôt le droit de
pouvoir partir à 60
de la gauche il y a des divergences 70
groupes socialiste aussi il y en a qui
sont pour le maintien à 62 d'autres qui
sont pour un retour à 60 ans
mieux parce que c'est une position j'ai
envie de dire équilibrer la position du
PS et de l'accord de la nuque c'est une
position du groupe socialiste ou
m'interroger là-dessus il faudra
interroger Monsieur Olivier Faure s'il
considère que l'accord de la nuque voilà
emporte l'accord des socialistes en
général d'un autre débat en commission a
été adopté un amendement pour que les
maires de famille bénéficient d'une
surcote après 63 ans est-ce que vous le
voterez c'est très c'est un quelque
chose qui est très cher semble-t-il
manifestement donc on verra bien ce que
dira le gouvernement mais oui c'est une
mesure positive de reconnaissance
simplement quand vous regardez
les commissaires aux affaires sociales
examiné cela dans de bonnes conditions
mais tout ce qui ira dans le bon sens
tout ce qui protégera mieux les citoyens
nous y sommes favorables mais la
meilleure la meilleure des méthodes
c'est de ne pas augmenter l'âge de la
retraite quoi finalement envoyer ce que
j'appelais les sucrettes
on pourrait éviter les sucrettes si on
ne touchait pas là je le gale il y a une
autre une autre mesure qui a été adoptée
en commission c'est la création d'un CDI
senior là aussi qui coûte cher un
Gabriel Attali à parler de 800 millions
est-ce que là vous votre aussi moi je
suis assez réservé je ne vous cache pas
et d'ailleurs je suis pas le seul
manifestement la CFDT la évoqué hier
assez réservé à des contrats au rabais
attention de ne pas faire des catégories
différentes
un senior c'est pas un travailleur à
part
un senior c'est un travailleur c'est un
salarié et il a le droit à voir les
mêmes droits les mêmes devoirs que
n'importe quel autre salarié et je pense
que si on commence à mettre des stat
particulier pour les seniors et bien on
continuera à les pousser vers un statut
je dirais sociétal qui est différent et
d'ailleurs il y a une étude très récente
qui vient de sortir de lunésique je ne
sais pas si vous l'avez vu qu'il montre
que le passage de 60 ans à 60 ans en
avait provoqué
un très grand nombre de chômeurs
supplémentaires 100 000 chômeurs en 10
ans entre 2012 et 2022 chez les seniors
ce qui veut dire que quand on augmente
l'âge de départ à la retraite tout
d'abord il y a plus d'arrêt maladie il
faut le savoir c'est comme ça et ça on
le calcule jamais et puis surtout ça
incite finalement les employeurs à
considéré que ces salariés qui coûtent
plus cher que les autres parce qu'ils
ont une carrière et bien on veut s'en
débarrasser donc voyez
il y a des effets collatéraux qu'on ne
mesure pas encore à ce stade
pas qu'il y a une nécessité à faire une
réforme de retraite quelle est la
Contre-Réforme qu'il faudrait faire et
financer comment alors tout d'abord il y
a des mesures de fond que nous voudrions
voir rétablir au niveau gras la question
des Outre-mer on évoquera la question de
la pénibilité je voulais évoquer donc
des modèles de société différents de
ceux qui sont prévus par cette réforme
qui et ça a été rappelé à plusieurs
reprises n'est qu'une réforme budgétaire
financière et finalement et c'est notre
collègue Monique humain qui l'a dit à
juste titre est-ce que c'est une réforme
du financement des retraites ou ce que
je suis une réforme du financement de
l'État
c'est une réforme du financement de
l'État puisqu'elle a été intégrée dans
le pacte de stabilité proposé à
Bruxelles et donc on met une réforme
faite pour sauver le régime par
répartition comme le dit le gouvernement
c'est un gage donné à Bruxelles pour
dire on va des on va trouver 17 18
milliards d'euros par an pour
rééquilibrer le budget de l'État
français donc ça c'est un choix ce n'est
pas le nôtre pourquoi ce n'est pas le
nôtre parce que si il manque et nous le
disons quand on annonce 150 milliards
d'euros cumulés de déficit oui c'est
vrai et on ne peut pas laisser filer les
finances publiques moi j'appartenus à un
gouvernement avec François Hollande qui
avait comme obsession de respecter les
fameux 3% de déficit ainsi que vous le
savez très bien donc il faut trouver
d'autres moyens de financement le
financement qui a été trouvé par le
gouvernement c'est je fais payer tout le
monde je fais payer tout le monde
un distinctement le tout le monde je
rappelle les chiffres si Français sur 10
si vous ramenez ça à la population
active ça fait combien ça fait 18
millions de Français vous vous allez
travailler vous êtes dans ces 10
millions de français Madame est-ce qu'il
y a d'autres solutions la réponse est
oui et alors on pourrait dire oui on va
taxer on va augmenter les cotisations ça
peut être dans le dans le panier de
entre guillemets dedans
je tiens à dire quand même que le dogme
du moins d'impôt que porte monsieur
Gabriel tal ça commence à coûter cher
entre 2017 et 2027 en projection toute
les mesures fiscales prises par le
gouvernement c'est 500 milliards d'euros
vous entendez bien 500 milliards d'euros
de recettes fiscales en moins dans les
caisses de l'État et à un moment donné
s'il y a moins de recettes et bien les
dépenses on les on les on les supprime
et donc faut arrêter avec le moins
d'impôts non seulement il faut arrêter
mais peut-être qu'il faut revenir sur
certaines d'entre elles les les 30
milliards de moins d'impôts sur les
impôts de production je vais dire où est
le retour aujourd'hui donc moi j'ai une
solution très simple sur deux sur deux
mesures l'emploi des seniors il faut
vraiment y aller et ça ramènerait à peu
près 5 milliard d'euros de recettes
supplémentaires dans la caisse de l'État
et l'égalité des salaires hommes femmes
c'est 5 à 6 milliards d'euros mais voilà
je vous ai trouvé le financement de la
retraite par répartition telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui je reviens à la
procédure puisque il y a une notion
référendaire on l'a dit est-ce qu'après
vous lancerez une procédure pour un
référendum d'initiative populaire sur ce
texte
je sais pas impossible sachant que il y
a un délai d'un an vous le savez pour le
faire ça peut être intéressant ça peut
être jouable mais la priorité ce sera
les recours devant le Conseil
constitutionnel
on a de quoi faire vous voyez je vais
vous donner là aussi un exemple très
concret
l'article qui concerne la création d'un
indices d'un indice d'index chercher le
mot sur les seniors n'a aucune
compétence financière aucune conséquence
financière et bien là voilà exactement
ce qu'on appelle un cavalier social et
je ne doute pas que le Conseil
constitutionnel va va tiquer sur le
sujet mais globalement il va tiquer sur
la procédure et d'ailleurs il paraît
qu'en privé mais je fais abusé c'est pas
très content le président du Conseil
constitutionnel en disant mais mais
comment peut-on utiliser un projet de
loi de finance de sécurité sociale pour
faire passer une réforme qui relèverait
d'une loi ordinaire donc nous sommes
devant des apprentis remercier si
j'étais un peu plus trivial je dirais
une somme devant un mécano qui a été
agité par des bricoleurs mais ce sera au
Conseil constitutionnel dans décider
dans le Canada précédent en tout cas
là on voit quand même les limites du jeu
les limites du jeu c'est un gouvernement
qui aujourd'hui lâche des milliards ici
des millions par là alors que donc il y
a eu un manque d'anticipation manifeste
un dernier mot pour terminer sur la
gauche vous avez été très critique
envers la manière dont les débats se
sont déroulés à l'Assemblée nationale
notamment de la part de la France
insoumise est-ce que vous demandez à
Olivier fort de rompre avec la France
électoral qui s'est transformé peu à peu
en accord politique mais pour une une
élection qui m'attend derrière nous
c'est l'élection législative la nuque
moi je crois le nom de la gauche la
nuque
il y a des législatives en Ariège à la
fin du mois de mars partielle et Olivier
Faure ne soutient pas la candidate
soutenue par les socialistes il y a
soutient la candidate de la Ligue ce
sera nos instances nationales d'en
trancher le Conseil national va
valeroquer très prochainement donc voilà
moi je suivrai la position du Conseil
national du Parti socialiste
pas forcément la candidat socialiste moi
je pense que c'est une excellente
candidate il y a une sortante mais
l'Ariège n'est pas et pourtant j'aime
bien l'arrière j'aime beaucoup le foie
Gaston bobus et formidable mais voilà on
va pas tout lié à cela par contre ce que
je sais c'est que l'accord de la Nupe
qui a été bâti à un moment donné et bien
les choses ont évolué depuis et
manifestement nous verrons à partir des
sénatoriales aussi une forme de
rééquilibrage au sein de la nuque et je
le souhaite justement pour les
sénatoriales est-ce que vous souhaitez
des listes communes avec la France
insoumise ou est-ce qu'il n'y aura aucun
endroit avec des
adorable gagnant-gagnant est-ce qu'un
candidat elle est fille sur une liste
socialiste sur un scooter proportionnel
supportant plus si tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire bah oui ça va nous
amener des grands électeurs
supplémentaires je ne pense pas à titre
personnel voilà je pense que parce que
finalement elle est fille n'a pas de
grands électeurs et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'ils veulent s'implanter et
notamment par rapport aux élections
municipales de 2026
je souhaite qu'on me prouve que la
présence d'un candidat elle est fille
amène des grands électeurs
supplémentaires et non pas un fuir
et ce qui s'est passé à l'Assemblée je
peux vous dire moi j'ai entendu des
mères qui m'ont dit mais c'est pas
possible ce qui s'est passé c'est pas ce
qu'on demande de nos parlementaires donc
nous verrons bien il va encore coller de
l'eau sous les ponts avant le mois de
septembre je suis pour des accords
gagnants gagnants et c'est vrai que ces
accords gagnants gagnants je les vois
plus avec nos collègues verts et nos
collègues communistes qu'avec les filles
vous pensez que qu'est-ce qu'il sortira
pardon pour le groupe socialiste de
signatorial vous pensez gagner des
sénateurs vous craignez dans perdre
les deux mon général il peut y avoir des
pertes parce que non mais parce que si
vous voulez bah c'est vrai qu'on peut en
perdre quelques-uns là et on gagne
quelques unes au total je pense qu'on
aura une grande stabilité merci beaucoup
d'en parler avec vous de ces
sénatoriales au mois de septembre merci
d'avoir été notre invité on continue
notre émission spéciale réforme des
retraites tout de suite dans le